oh all right
Cree master
now my own personal history with the
Cree master cycle has flip-flopped
several times going back and forth from
positive to negative so in the interest
of brevity I've asked the dance to
reenact a decade of shifting opinion hey
Dan
you sure do hate Cree master don't you
boy do I ever have you ever actually
seen it nope but I've read all about it
well Dan that just seems wrong you
should probably go see it before you
start judging it yeah I guess you're
right I'll shut up until I actually see
it
hey Cree master 2 is showing at the
Uptown yay
that was terrible
to be perfectly honest Cree master to
surprised me it was terrible in ways
that I wasn't expecting okay so before
we even get started with anything I'm
going to lay it out there
Cree master is bad these are the films
that normal people imagine when they
hear art film nightmarish ugly and
senseless but in a way that somehow
extremely boring the entire reason we're
going to dig into it is so that we can
learn to understand bad art it does just
about everything wrong and the things
that it does right barely break mediocre
honestly dissecting Cree masters a bit
like living with someone who has extreme
dementia so much is going wrong that it
feels like a great moment if they
remember to put pants on before they
leave the house sure it's only an
achievement in context and you wouldn't
expect anything less from other people
but right here right now they're a
superstar speaking of context the Cree
master cycle is the food baby of Matthew
Barney an ex-jock with an anal fetish
and a deep love for his balls in the
late 80s he was playing varsity football
for Yale but realized that he had little
to no hope of making it in the NFL so he
got an art degree instead somewhere in
there he discovered that if you give
your homemade pornography a fancy name
you can sell it as art and he began to
produce videos where he would stuff
things up his butt or hang things from
his anus and scrotum with titles like
mile high threshold flight with the anal
sadistic warrior and field dressing
aurifil he also likes to climb like rock
climbing that comes up a bunch after
selling some home porn to lower Eastside
Manhattanites Barney started project
that he described with terms like brazen
and epic the five part Cree master cycle
a self-contained aesthetics system
constituting sculpture photography and
performance art with five films as the
centerpiece it would turn out to be
neither brazen epic nor film but will
come to all that in time first a history
lesson about good art the movie has its
roots in abstract and surrealist art and
is often compared to the far far better
film by Luis buñuel and Salvador Dali
yes that Sal
Oh dolly Chan and Alou
enchant Andalou or an Andalusian dog in
English was released in 1929 in Paris
and is an attempt to recreate the
experience of the dream world on film
there is no story or plot and scenes
just transition from one to another
without concern for continuity or
narrative and there is no intrinsic
meaning dalian Boone L wanted to play
with the conscious psyches demand for
meaning even though the unconscious
dreaming psyche will casually accept
bizarre non sequitur scenarios you see
when you're awake your mind wants to put
things into spatial and sequential order
because it needs that information to
navigate the world but in a dream
anything goes you can even change from
one identity to another without a break
in continuity this is the root of
Surrealism hallucinations illusions in
the dreamscape things that bear enough
of an anchor to the real that you can
identify them but are in some way wrong
or unreal enchant Andalou is fascinating
to watch if only to see how casually
your brain accepts or tries to accept
the nonsensical transitions and
scenarios once you've eased into the
film
oh and it's only 16 minutes long we'll
come back to that too briefly we need to
touch on two other concepts that are
going to be important then we can get to
Cree master I promise we're getting
there
post-modernism is an art movement that
started vaguely in the late 1800s and
early 1900s and in many ways surrealism
is regarded as a sibling or maybe a
subsection of post-modernism since the
principal concern of post-modernism is
the concept of the real and the
impossibility of objective truth and
surrealism is you know all about
screwing with perception there's a lot
more to post-modernism but the main
concept that's survived and the first of
our two concepts we need to remember is
the idea of the meta something that we
discussed a bit when we talked about
Enter the Void the idea of the meta is
that the art doesn't exist in the
physical realm but is only given form
and meeting in the discussion about the
object that is the focus of the art
through this lens a painting is just a
bunch of canvas and chemicals and it's
the discussion about those objects that
creates the art and the meaning over
time we've come to more or less accept
that art isn't that one-dimensional but
it's also not a purely physical thing
either meta-level discussion forms a
significant portion of meaning and
appreciation which is why taste and
interpretation is shift over time but
you still need to have something to talk
about in the first place then you have
the conceptualist the conceptual list
took the meta to a whole new level
elevating process or means of production
as the central value of their art in
essence it's not about the final product
it's about what you used and how you got
there okay that doesn't sound too wacky
I guess life's a journey and all that
right well no the centerpiece of the
conceptualist toolbox is the artist
statement the art itself is typically
performance art but in order to avoid
being pigeon-holed into existing
performance art forms like dance theater
and music the conceptualist try to find
new things to do like masturbating in
public hammering nails into their own
dicks and a variety of other things that
you could expect to find at a
particularly rowdy kink night or circus
sideshow so how do you take what is
ultimately little more than an
exhibitionist freak show and turn it
into art you write your own multi-page
essay telling the audience what it means
and you make sure that it has a
religious or political bent to it
ensuring that you'll make someone angry
so that they'll start talking about it
to creating a meta-level discourse that
makes it art yeah so to recap really
quickly surrealist art plays with ideas
about reality and dreams in the lack of
true meaning post-modernism made
meta-level discussion of meaning and
importance an integral part of the
artwork and conceptualism made the
meta-level discussion and means of
production the central focus with the
product itself merely a catalyst that's
where Barney comes in on the scale with
performance work that's somewhere
between ass fetish and extreme sports
being gussied up with faults meeting and
meta discourse after selling a few home
movies where he floods his anus with
petroleum jelly he found some disciples
willing to pour money his way and in
1994 he released the first video in the
Cree master cycle which would in the end
form one giant seven-hour video so
what's it all about it's all about balls
no seriously it's about balls the Kree
master muscle is the tiny muscle that
controls the raising and lowering of the
testicles within the scrotum and the
entire cycle is about the process of
sexual differentiation in the fetus and
right away this is where things start
going off the rails because this
metaphor isn't apparent from watching
the videos well okay the balls part is
obvious since testicles and ovaries
litter the imagery but that's all these
images are just there they show up on
screen then they go away no effort is
made to inject commentary insight or
emotion into the subject matter and the
overarching theme of differentiation is
treated just as blandly and vaguely the
only thread that tries to chart things
is the recurrence of this symbol called
the field emblem a symbol that Barney
made up that has no meaning outside of
the cycle in order to know what the
cycle is talking about you'll need to
refer to the artists statement which you
can find on the official web site or in
the official cree master cycle companion
book available now for only 900 dollars
yeah
this is ultimately going to be two of
the greatest flaws with the cycle first
everything you see in here has one true
meaning and any ideas you come up with
are probably wrong because Matthew
Barney said so second everything is just
an inside reference to the cycle itself
you need the book to understand the
videos and you need the videos to
understand the book it's control and
marketing and it doesn't stop with a
grotesquely expensive concordance hell
it barely starts there
you're probably wondering where you can
find a copy of the Cree master cycle so
you can see if it's actually all that
bad Netflix nope Amazon nope blockbuster
nope the Cree master cycle only shows up
in art galleries in the occasional
cinema only twenty copies have been
officially produced on DVD and those
were auctioned off for upwards of half a
million dollars why do it that way it's
not available in any sort of mass market
or even a reasonably accessible legal
form because Barney doesn't want you to
see it he wants you to talk about it and
read the books his friends wrote not
watch it because if all you do is talk
about it and read about it then your
plaintiff exposure is tightly controlled
and limited to that pillar of
conceptualism the artist statement he
wants you to visit the official website
where you can look at a select few
photographs and read about how visually
stunning the images are and how
brilliant and deep the meaning is he
doesn't want you to see the washed out
colors bad video sloppy editing terrible
pacing horrible sound and crappy sets so
if you want to see it you're going to
have to resort to either traveling
halfway around the world or spending
five seconds looking for a bootleg copy
online join me next week as we dig into
the actual videos
uh-huh yeah which I wanna do wannabe
ballers shot-callers ballers will be
dipping in the bends with the spoilers
on the low from the dick and the
tourists trying to get my hands on some
grass like